in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche bella find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape
and joining us in the studio to talk
about this condition is rania bugari a
skin specialist who treats hyperhidrosis
welcome to the show hi and dr bugari
what makes certain people sweat too much
well actually sweating is a very
important function in the body to
regulate the
the temperature
but in some cases you have you have the
people who have the hyperhidrosis
it can be like a primary hyperheterosis
where you don't find a reason for the
sweating or you have the secondary
hyperheterosis which is most of the time
in combination with some medical uh
treatments or like illnesses diseases uh
which can occur then so what kind of
diseases i mean the thyroid gland for
instance for instance or like um
diabetes or or like if you have some
tumors also it's like the be symptomatic
called they sweat cold sweats in the
night
and they have
other symptoms so it's very important if
a patient comes to you to the practice
that you you see what kind of sweating
do you have here should i say okay it's
a primary sweating or should i make
other diagnostic like
control from some other functions also
so for the patient it's um important as
well to go and see a doctor if the
patient sweats too much because there
could be an underlying cause yes of
course because yeah and if there's no
cause for the sweating so it's a primary
sweating what's the problem with it
anyway i mean is it just a cosmetic
problem a psychological problem or are
there any health issues combined well i
think most of the time you have a very
very
high
psychological problem because these
patients who are suffering on this
excessive sweating they're really
suffering in their
daily lives they they have difficulties
with their relationships with others
with their friends also in the jobs like
if they have a presentation or if they
have um like also students
they can't write their exams because
they're sweating excessively on the
hands and it's a really
really um
difficult situation for these big
psychological problems yes it's a very
big psychological problems there are
also the studies which showed that the
patients who suffer on hyper hydration
has more psychological problems than
others like they have
other diseases on the skin removing all
the sweat glands is nice idea because if
there are no glands you cannot sweat but
are there any long-term effects or risks
with that operation
i think that the problem is that you
can't remove all the glands on the area
because you you just like don't see the
glands you you do like a liposuction on
the area where you're sweating and
this is
the effect that you sweat less but
sometimes it's a problem because you
still sweat on this area and it's like
like not enough and it's also an
operation and the operation has at risks
because you may like
um have an infection on this area and
that's why i advise to go to a
specialist who does this operation um
lots of the time yeah just let the
specialist do this because he knows or
she knows what she's doing i remember a
patient in my office who was sweating
excessively on the hands and they didn't
remove any glands they just clipped the
nerves so they destroyed the nerve in
the armpit and so this patient wasn't
sweating any longer in the hands yeah
this is a real
i would say it's not love the first
treatment i would recommend because
there are some other ways to treat
sweating on the hands but if our all
other ways don't give the the effective
result so you can you can recommend this
operation if they're really suffering
under it because it's also a big
operation which should be done in a
center um because you can also cut some
other nerves and then you have
other diseases or like the horner's
syndrome
so i don't think that it's really the
first so it's not only the good nerve
damage you can even remove some
beneficial work off the nerves and this
kind of patient i had he was sweating on
the hands and after they cut the nurse
the sweating stopped in the hands but he
was sweating more excessively from the
rest part of his body is it the usual
thing these are the side effects so this
is the most side effect that these
people are very happy at first because
like they're not sweating more on the
hands but then they sweat all over the
body so
yeah
so so it's not very beneficial so i
think yeah what about botox you can just
give this kind of nerve poison into the
glands yes you you'll just like you and
botox is a really a very good treatment
for sweating because you can like give
it all over the in each area of the body
you can use it and most of the time you
use it for under um the arms because it
goes really fast and you see you see the
results after
three four days and the patients are
really happy about this
well if you like if you're sweating on
the arms or on the feet it's a little
bit more difficult i see because they
have more pain but if you like do a
local anesthesia before the the patients
tolerate this and they're also happy
about the results so it's it's a really
very good and um but it's a kind of
intervention i mean it's not a surgery
but it's it's intervention but what
about the household things our viewer
limbaugh gibbourbauting from ghana wants
to know which kind of antiperspirants
she should use yeah um i would say the
antiperspirants are usually the first
treatment which most of the patients
because like they they're going in
internet and they're searching and and
most of the time you have these
perspectives with aluminium chloride and
they have to use it on the area most of
the time it works very good
under the arms but it's sometimes
difficult for the hands and for the feet
and so
you have to like see the the
concentration of aluminium chloride
because it sometimes irritates the skin
when you have a very concentrated
solution and you have to use it at night
before you go to sleep you have to wash
the area before and i think if you use
it
in the right way it will help you but
but not hundred percent and if you don't
want to just go into a shop and and buy
something go and see your doctor and yes
i think yes i think you should
go and see the doctors thanks so much
for being with us in the studio thank
you